the speed of an orbiting object is
caused by the gravity pulling on it
gravity is stronger when there is more
mass so the more mass there is in here
the faster this object will go
distance also affects the strength of
gravity
so an object out here will go slower
because the force is weaker out there
it's the same for galaxies this stuff is
really far away so should be going
pretty slow but when we measure it it's
going way too fast
this could be explained by adding some
matter in here as we go out to give it
the speed
that matter is dark matter
there are two things dark matter could
be
ordinary stuff called machos
or massive compact halo objects that we
can't really see like failed stars and
cold dust that sits around like bricks
supplying that extra mass
or it could be extraordinary stuff
wimps
weakly interacting massive particles
a new kind of particle with mass
but that doesn't interact with anything
so we can't really see it but we are
searching for clues